i feel like i need to give you a
forewarning for this video because what
you're about to watch
may sound like one of the craziest
things to ever be suggested about the
legend of zelda keep in mind while
watching that this is in fact a theory
not explicitly proven in-game or being
heralded as being proven but rather is
an interesting what if kind of scenario
that i believe has some pretty decent
merit which is exactly the kind of video
that i love doing on the channel i was
also helped by some of my fantastic
fellow theorists over in my discord
server and will be crediting them each
fully at the end of the video so please
be sure to stay tuned for that
now without further ado let's delve into
the final masked nintendo bandit theory
for 2020. we're all familiar with
ocarina of time right
no alright let me refresh your memory
real quick link the hero of time draws
the master sword and travels into the
future by
seven years defeats ganondorf with the
help of the sages and zelda who seals
the demon king in the realm of the
beyond
then sends link back in time to the now
child timeline to relive his child's
days
those days continue into the events of
majora's mask and centuries later the
events of twilight princess
etc etc but let me pause right there and
rewind a bit because i already passed
what the focal point of this entire
theory is about you see
when zelda plays the ocarina of time and
sends link back in time by seven years
something strange happens link had
previously been sort of fast forwarding
into the future by drawing the sword and
rewinding back into the past by placing
it into its pedestal as evidenced by
his age but now when zelda sent link
back in time for the final time using
the ocarina of time
the hero of time was rewound into the
past like before but this time since the
sword was not involved in his time
travel
he was also actually removed from the
current adult timeline
and placed instead in the child timeline
shattering the connection between the
two points in time and instead creating
two completely different timelines
this specific piece of lore isn't ever
debated and is evidenced by the official
timeline and
beginning animation of the game wind
waker when it details the legend of the
hero of time
who simply appears out of nowhere and
then disappears from their timeline
after defeating ganon
never to be seen again and after the
credits role in ocarina of time
link is shown to be kind of waking up in
this new child timeline where zelda sent
him with the master sword sitting
quietly in front of him
this is what i wanted to talk about the
master sword you see i'd like to propose
a question that has the potential to
change the legend of zelda as we know it
and that question is this what if the
master sword was also removed along with
link from the adult timeline let's talk
about why this is a possibility first
and then we'll talk about why it's a
probability
visually we can see that zelda uses the
ocarina and does in fact send link back
in time with the master sword still
on his back and when link is shown next
he's glancing with surprise at his body
realizing he's a child again something
that hasn't surprised him since the very
first time he drew the master sword
implying very strongly that this wasn't
his doing he didn't place the master
sword back in the pedestal this time
it was most likely the work of zelda and
the ocarina sending him there but the
evidence here is more than just visual
in twilight princess which features this
very same master sword as it takes place
in the timeline
shown here the hero of twilight draws
the sword from the pedestal that's
present in the ruins of the temple of
time that now exists in the sacred grove
the temple of time later on in the game
becomes a dungeon that link must
complete and he enters it by traveling
to the temple of time's past and placing
the master sword in its pedestal
in the past do you see what i'm saying
link has now traveled at this point to a
point in time before he drew the sword
from this pedestal
yet the sword is not present here in the
past it's also unlikely that the sword
was just simply taken by someone in the
past as it is shown in many games to
only accept the hero as its wielder
and the hero of twilight is most likely
the hero that appeared immediately
following the hero of time since he is
visited by the hero of time aka the hero
shade
i believe that what this means is that
this master sword
being a relic created by the goddesses
themselves transcends time and can only
be present in one time frame or timeline
at a time
otherwise link should have come across
the duplicate master sword when he
walked through a portal to the past and
yes i know that there are several
appearances of the master sword in the
fallen timeline
but that timeline isn't like the adult
and child ones the fallen timeline is
actually not a timeline split but is
rather an alternate reality that happens
if link is defeated meaning it operates
on a different set of rules and can
indeed feature the same blade at the
same time
bringing it back though if we apply this
evidence and logic to the master sword
that has seemingly followed link back in
time at the end of ocarina of time we
can fairly safely deduce that it was in
fact removed from the adult timeline
which is crazy to think about because it
forces us to ask this next question
if this is the case then what sword does
link draw in the wind waker if
the master sword is no longer present in
the adult timeline
well naturally he draws the master sword
are you confused yet
good let's continue what if this is a
different
man-made master sword we know that the
people of hyrule are no strangers to
attempting to make other master swords
as
is evidenced by the royal guard swords
in breath of the wild which are said to
be attempted replicas of the legendary
blade using shika technology so let's
assume for a moment that they were
successful
and this is in fact another master sword
there are several differences between
this blade of evil's bane and the
previous blade of evil's bane that i'd
like to point out
the first and most prevalent being its
drastically different appearance wind
waker was created with a completely
different more
cartoony art style which is one thing
but while the blade does bear some
similarities
this master sword features a different
coloration a different hilt
a different handle and a strange symbol
at the top of its handle that isn't
present
anywhere on the original master sword
and by the way nintendo is more than
capable of designing the blade to look
roughly the same across different games
as they've done with skyrid sword
ocarina of time
twilight princess and breath of the wild
which have each also featured different
art styles
albeit not quite as drastic as wind
wakers secondly the master sword from
wind waker is in a completely different
location than where it was previously
its previous location being the temple
of time in the wind waker the sword is
present in a new chamber located
underneath hyrule castle that is
surrounded by images of the sages from
ocarina of time
a new chamber of the sages if you will
the master sword has
never been kept inside the castle before
or since
this blade also requires the prayers of
two new sages to empower it with the
power to defeat evil
when previously it was none other than
the goddess hylia herself who blessed
the blade with that very power
the sages were not a part of the process
at all and finally there's also the fact
that the blade serves to effectively
lock the entirety of hyrule in a time
stasis which once again is a unique
trait never seen before or since
there is also some evidence we can
gather from ganondorf's knowledge of the
blade
when link first confronts the dark lord
he laughs at the young heroes attempt to
slay him but what ganondorf says at this
time is particularly
interesting he says that the blade is
also a sort of key
a most wretched little key that has kept
a seal on me
and my magic intact and then he goes on
to say
what you hold is useless go back to the
world below and tell that to the
pathetic fools who made this blade
there are two very big lore bombs he
just dropped the first being that the
blade has been responsible for sealing
his power and his monsters away
this contrasts where and how he was
previously sealed at the end of ocarina
of time at the end of that game
zelda states in the original japanese
version that ganondorf had been sealed
by the sages into the world of
darkness meaning he was not sealed in
any part inside the original master
sword
and i'll come back to why later on in
this video secondly he states that link
should take the blade back down to the
world below
meaning hyrule and tell the quote
pathetic
fools who made this blade that its power
has vanished this is actually huge as it
implies the blade's creators to be
residents of hyrule i highly doubt he
would be referring to the goddesses as
being in the land below and also being
you know
pathetic fools if anything ganondorf
respects the goddesses and even prays to
them at the end of the game as all he
wants is their
triforce so that he can bring glory to
the land of gerudo but you know who he
would call pathetic
the sages who previously sealed him away
but that's besides the point what we now
have is a blade that looks differently
functions differently and is located in
a different place than the original
blade of evil spain
which was most likely removed from this
timeline finally
it's time to piece all of this together
let's take a look at what i believe
happened before the events of the wind
waker that led to this duplicate blade
being made
in the age following the hero of time
and original master sword's
disappearance the mortals of hyrule
experienced a time of peace the seven
sages who were still around after link's
disappearance as evidenced in the sword
chamber
remembered the final words of ganondorf
which promised that he would return so
long as he held the triforce of power
since they knew he would eventually
return and the master sword was no
longer around
they created a new master sword that
operated off of their sage power for the
next hero to wield against the demon
king
an age passed the sage's numbers for
whatever reason dwindled down
to two eventually ganon did indeed break
out of the sage's seal and once again
terrorized the people of hyrule the
hyruleans then prayed to the gods above
for the return of the hero of time
but no hero appeared which by the way if
you're interested i have another video
covering which will be linked in the
description below it was at this time
that i believe the king and the allies
of the goddesses took matters into their
own hands to save the land of hyrule as
we see from the wind waker
the king was the individual who was
behind the breaking of the triforce of
wisdom in an attempt to hide it and the
princess from ganondorf
who wanted the completed triforce but
even though the triforce of courage had
also been shattered and scattered across
the land
they knew this was all at most a simple
hindrance to the dark lord and they
still needed a hero to arise in order to
defeat ganon once and for all but
still no hero appeared with his backup
against the wall and no one and nowhere
to turn to
the king then made a plea to the gods
above who as we know decided to flood
the land of hyrule but according to the
king gave the hylian some time to
prepare
i believe he and the sages then laid a
trap for ganondorf and his forces by
allowing them to enter the castle and
then
freezing them in time with the sage and
possibly sheikah made master sword
taking some highlands to the
mountaintops and then allowing the gods
to flood the world below in hopes of
sealing ganondorf beneath the waves
forever
in the beautiful destroyed land of
hyrule but of course
ganon was not so easily defeated he once
again broke free of his seal and emerged
atop the waves and established the
forsaken fortress
ganondorf who now knew of a new blade
existing under the waves
then killed the final remaining sages
that were empowering the blade in the
earth and wind temples
partially in an attempt to free his
power from the world below
but also preventing the blade from being
able to be used by
any potential hero and also explaining
why he knew of its lack of power in the
game ganondorf had been burned once
before by allowing and underestimating a
young boy to obtain the legendary blade
and though he was unsure of the
existence of a current hero
he was not about to make that same
mistake twice then
the events of the game transpire and
when link who had not only retrieved the
master sword but also led two
new sages to the temples in order to
empower it once more defeated ganondorf
with the blade at the end of the game
the sword seals ganondorf by turning him
to stone
something the blade accomplished by the
power of the sages that has never been
seen before
or since the king racked with guilt from
wishing for the demise of his beloved
land of hyrule
wished now for its final destruction
leading to the land
her king the demon and the blade
sleeping forever at the bottom of the
ocean
it's the ultimate story of mortals
trying desperately to save themselves
from their own demise
and it all started with the forging of a
new master sword
but that is just our theory what do you
think
is the master sword actually a different
blade in the wind waker or the same
blade every time it shows up
let me know in the comments below hey
guys thank you so much for watching
please give this video a like if you
enjoyed watching as it will help spread
the video around on youtube more than
you know
and subscribe to the channel if you
haven't already to stick around in 2021
which is crazy but it's right around the
corner as i mentioned at the start of
this video i was helped in this theory
immensely by the good theorists over on
my discord server
including but not limited to law online
historian aka
the dad laurelian historian barrow the
scientician
legend zone who actually has his own
youtube channel linked below and
staying says thank you guys for helping
this theory come to life and if i missed
anyone
please feel free to make yourself known
in the comments below and i'll give it a
heart
as always huge thanks to my amazing
supporters and say hi to the new faces
of kade
cows eat pie and selena rose who have
all joined the ranks of my elite you
guys make my day every day and have made
this holiday season the best one ever
if you're interested in supporting the
channel and having a hand in making the
next video come to life
please feel free to check out that join
button located below any of my videos or
the links in the description below for
my patreon page
also there are only a couple days left
to pick up some 100k
limited edition mmb merch so please
check out the store also in the
description below and use the code
happy100 for 10
off any order that's all i've got for
this one so as always i hope you have a
wonderful rest of your year and i'm
sorry for my dogs barking in the
background right now
but really thank you for watching my
videos thank you for 2020.
i hope to see you next year this is
masantana bandit
signing out
[Music]